منعطف جديد في مسار المواجهه مع طهران
تدخله واشنطن صحيفه نيويورك تايمز قالت ان
البيت الابيض غير استراتيجته اتجاه ايران
اجتماعات باتي يخصصها الامن القومي
لمناقشه خطط تقويم النوويه وتوفير معدات
اتصالات للمتظاهرين بدل مناقشه استراتيجيه
التفاوض للعوده للاتفاق النووي
الرئيس الامريكي
الجديد تقول الصحيفه بعد توقف المفاوضات
وما تلى ذلك من فرض عقوبه امريكيه جديده
على طهران
الشعبيه في ارجاء ايران في الولايات
المتحده اتهم هذا الاسبوع بانتهاك الاراضي
العراقيه عبر شانها جامعه استهدفت اقليم
كردستان العراق ومن خلال تقيمات العامه
التي قدمتها اداره بعيدا فقد احرزت ايران
تقدما كبيرا بحيث بات بامكان تخزين الوقود
المناسب لصنع القنبله النوويه في غضون
اسابيع هو اسلوب جديد تنهجه الولايات
المتحده في مواجهه ايران ما يجعل اي عوده
للاتفاق النووي تبدو غير وارده في الوقت
المنظور على الاقل بلال الوجديني العربيه